Let's play a quick round of-
Drewth or dare!
(audience cheer and clap)
We still say that.
Every time.
All right, so I actually do, if you don't mind,
I'd like to switch it up a little bit today.
If you don't mind, I dare you Drew.
I'm gonna dare you to surprise a member
of our audience here who's a big fan of the show.
Okay well, I did hear about a Todd Weinstein.
He is in the audience.
Look, he's just looking over there.
Todd, are you surprised?
(Ross laughs)
(audience laugh)
Hi, come on down.
Come on right down here Todd, come on.
(audience cheer and clap)
Surprise!
Wow.
Well, hi.
Are you surprised?
Speechless.
I like this.
Speechless, wow, wow.
Well, so your wife wrote in
and she told us that you're getting ready
to start a canned food drive for your 50th birthday.
Will you tell us about it?
I might start crying.
(audience clap)
I am so inspired by your story.
I was wondering how did you get the idea for it?
Well, I work with this food pantry in Long Island
and I run a community group called Nice Things That Happen
in East Meadow.
It's our big shout out.
So it's really about community goodness where we live.
What you're doing really speaks to me.
It inspires me and it's like who I really wanna be
and who I'm trying to be.
And we know that The INN
is a charity very near and dear to your heart.
Is that correct?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Okay well, we're gonna donate $1,000 to them
(audience clap)
and of course I'm gonna match it, so that's another $1,000.
So we'd like to donate $2,000.
Oh my goodness.
And then would it be okay to put your organization up
on our website and drive traffic to it
so that we can keep supporting you?
We're a close group.
Gotta gotta live in our town, that's it.
I mean, you could become our friend, but-
No outsiders?
Denied!
I love it.
No, the answer is no.
No, no.
Well we do wanna support you.
Wow.
Yeah.
And we won't say anything negative.
Wow, absolutely.
Thank you, I would love to, what is it called again?
Nice Things That Happen in East Meadow.
I mean-
Nice Things That Happen
in East Meadow.
In East Meadow.
Can we please promote you on our website?
Well then you gotta do me a favor then.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm turning 50 in June
and I wanted to do parties and stuff and craziness,
but I wanna do a canned food drive.
And I wanted to collect 1,972 cans of food
for our food pantry.
That's what I was gonna announce.
I would love to have a little video
of Drew Barrymore introducing this food drive
on our page.
We can do that.
I actually know Drew Barrymore.
I know, right.
I could make that happen.
And if you'll have me, I would love to do this.
I really would.
Well, if you don't mind, I'll make you that video today.
Fantastic.
Maybe we could be members of your Facebook
even though we don't live in the area.
We know we're friends.
You're welcome to visit our town.
We'll be nice, I promise.
Thank you for inspiring us with what you're doing
and choosing to celebrate your 50 birthday.
You've inspired us, thank you.
Wow.
(audience cheer and clap)
Thank you, we love you.
Thank you Todd.
I'm gonna make you that video.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)